had exposure to mathematics at a very
early age my father is a mathematician
so I was always interested in what my
father was doing in school that was
naturally wrong in mathematics and
physics my PhD was in the physics
department but it was really a PhD in
mathematics I was always attracted to
the fact that the statements in
mathematics are permanent the field I
mean is central at the interface between
probability theory and mathematical
analysis or theory of partial
differential equations and one of the
big questions in the field is this
question of universality which says that
many systems exhibit very similar
essentially identical large-scale
behavior even though they're macroscopic
descriptions are very very different
there are some situations where this
large day behavior is not described by a
Gaussian object and these are extremely
poorly understood I was always
interested in the physics of sound
understanding what sounds are whoo what
they look like what they are made of so
there is a very indirect connection
between the analysis of sound and the
toolbox that I've been developing for
analyzing these Hellfest equations which
is that to some extent both of them rely
on wavelet analysis so I was walking to
my office when I suddenly realized that
wavelet analysis would give me a tool
that allows me to go from
one-dimensional systems to higher
dimensional systems and then also make
the analysis that I've previously done
of one-dimensional systems more robust
you can really get an idea anywhere any
moments it doesn't have to be in the
office it really helps to can do
something completely different
listen to music there's some cocaine but
still keep it at the back of your mind
I think it's really important to do
genuinely
curiosity-driven type of mathematics I
think it's only by being genuinely
curious about the problem and generally
interested in the problem that you would
be able to keep it in your head for
sufficiently long time or sort of think
upon it in a sufficiently focused way to
actually make sense for your progress
you